Daenerys continues to spark romance
rumors with philanthropists Alexandra
grant after walking the red carpet hand
in hand at the 2019 LACMA art and film
gala on Saturday night so after blowing
up social media with their red carpet
romance here's everything we know about
the rumored couple with Candace sporting
an all-black suit alongside Alexandra in
a dark blue gown the two packed on the
PDA on the red carpet but this isn't the
first time they've been spotted in
public together they're blossoming
romance was first seen at the MOCA
benefit in May and then at the Saint
Laurent Fashion Show back in June so
it's safe to say this just makes it
extra official now before turning heads
at Saturday night's event the duo were
previously business partners yeah they
actually collaborated on two books Oh to
happiness and shadows in 2011 and 2016
where candy was the featured writer in
Alexandria was the illustrator after a
successful run with both the poetry and
picture books the pair launched their
very own publishing company called X
artists books although neither keanu nor
his rep have confirmed their
relationship social media cannot get
enough of the Internet boyfriends new
girlfriend now the actor has publicly
remained single after the tragic
delivery of his stillborn daughter in
1999 followed by a car accident that
killed the child's mother and his
girlfriend Jennifer simi in 2001 so we
can only hope he has finally found
happiness even though my heart is broken
what do you think of Candy's rumored new
romance let us know in the comments
below